[Music]
we are definitely witnessing a phase
change a turning point in America's
relationship with cannabis sativa that's
right the marijuana plant a sacrament
that's been used for thousands of years
in all kinds of contexts for promoting
healing for promoting transformation for
promoting spirituality and every day
we're learning a host of new benefits
that are associated with the plant now I
think it's kind of amazing not just for
the fact that this plant is non-toxic
and has so many medicinal and
therapeutic benefits but also for the
fact that as a sacred sacrament this
raises the issue of cognitive liberty
the fact that as adult if we're not
hurting everybody else we should have
the right to explore the contours of our
own consciousness without any mediation
or legislation on the part of somebody
else prohibition as as Abraham Lincoln
used to say it goes beyond the bounds of
Reason and attempts to legislate a man's
appetite by making a crime of things
that are not crimes a paraphrasing but
you get the point but I think now the
majority of Americans support marijuana
legalization we're seeing more and more
states embrace this issue of cognitive
freedom and I say we're gonna see
transformation in consciousness
not to mention okay that marijuana is
extraordinarily sensitive to initial
rhetorical conditions it's what Timothy
Leary used to describe as set and
setting so by changing the context by
changing the culture in which people
partake in this visionary herb you're
changing the very nature of the
medicines effects experiments in
Colorado are raising the stage in which
people enjoy their cannabis we're
talking culinary experiences we're
talking classical music venues and
concerts we're talking special cinemas
with vaporizing rooms where people can
you know prime their brains but it has
maduk conversion it's a new world and
it's a world business gonna beat you
know it's gonna be interesting to see
how it all unfolds cognitive thrills
await us that we cannot even imagine
[Music]
you